vite et de france 24 jeanne suggère
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
avocat responsable de la commission
justice internationale amnesty la cour
pénale internationale cette semaine a
ouvert une enquête sur de possibles
crimes de guerre en ukraine sans faire
de justice fiction qui peut être
poursuivi est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
vladimir poutine par exemple peut se
retrouver devant la cpi
alors devant la cour pénale
internationale seuls les individus
peuvent être poursuivis donc pas les pas
les étangs
il ya trois ans
il a trois étapes devant la cour pénale
internationale examen préliminaire
banquette et puis possiblement si la
détermination des responsabilités et
fait ensuite un procès c'est possible
donc devant la compagnie natation il n'y
a pas d'immunité donc en théorie
effectivement toute personne quelle que
soit sa fonction officielle peut être
poursuivi sa gestion de la russie et de
l'ukraine vous savez que ces deux pays
n'ont pas ratifié la cour pénale
internationale un statut de la cour
pénale internationale néanmoins en 2014
et en 2015 le cren le parlement qu une
très nerveux fait des déclarations
reconnaissant la compétence de la cour
pénale internationale c'est la raison
pour laquelle depuis ce temps là depuis
2014 la cpi est compétente pour tous du
statut qui seraient commis sur son
territoire donc aujourd'hui c'est le
moment du recueil de preuves avec
l'annoncé de l'ouverture d'une enquête
alors je me suis à la cpi parle de
crimes de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité quelles la nuance
alors la nuance en fait c'est le
contexte les crimes de guerre ce sont
des crimes qui sont commis dans le cas
d'un conflit armé qu'il soit national ou
international
alors que les crimes contre l'humanité
sont des crimes qui peuvent être les
mêmes pour la victime ça peut être un
meurtre par exemple mais les crimes
contre l'humanité sont des crimes qu'ils
sont commis à l'encontre d'une
population civile et qui ont un
caractère massif systématique et ils
peuvent être commis en temps en temps de
paix donc ce sont des crimes dont la
qualification est différente à cause du
contexte en fait dans lequel j'écris
psion peut lui en ce moment il est
question vous l'avez dit 2 recueil de
preuves comment ces preuves
peuvent-elles être recueillies dans ce
contexte site de bombardements de
violence toute la difficulté notamment
de la cour pénale internationale qui
interagit en temps réel donc les
déclarations du programme carré de
cannes son savoir que l' enquête est
donc ouverte grâce au fait qu'il ya eu
39 états et c'est la première fois c'est
historique c'est la première fois que
des états européens saisissent d'une
situation la cour pénale internationale
donc toute l'union européenne plus un
certain nombre d'autres pays donc
aujourd'hui la difficulté évidemment ses
lacs ses preuves c'est la préservation
des preuves aussi c'est la sécurité des
enquêteurs tout ça c'est un extrêmement
difficile puisqu'on est dans une justice
qui finalement interagir en temps réel
et justement est ce qu'on peut imaginer
que la cpi essaye de travailler via des
commissions rogatoires sur un théâtre de
guerre ou louent les hommes sont
mobilisés
oui elle fera m en tout cas la cpi fera
tout ce qui est en son possible pour
recueillir les preuves et once préserver
les preuves puisque aujourd'hui la laddh
il a vraiment la priorité pour la course
de préserver ses preuves de préserver
que ces frais soient détruites
mercy james les airs pour vos
explications je rappelle que vous êtes
avocate responsable de la commission
justice internationale amnesty merci
côté diplôme